it's a modern-day David versus Goliath
story The billion dooll epic games picks
a fight with the trillion doll Google
and comes out with a decisive legal
Victory but the prize is not money it's
much bigger than that and could
dramatically change the mobile app
development landscape as we know it it
is December 12th 2023 and you're
watching the code report programmers
make for terrible lawyers and I'm a
programmer but luckily I have a lawyer
friend who helped me analyze this case
so epic games makes video games you may
have heard of like fortnite in addition
to the unreal game engine now on the
Google Play store apps that have over1
million in Revenue are required to pay a
30% cut for any inapp purchases simply
put epic games thinks these fees are
exorbitant and unfair it believes Google
holds an illegal Monopoly with the Play
Store and Google Play billing what's
interesting though is that Android is an
open source platform based on Linux and
there are alternative app stores out
there where you can distribute Android
apps without Google although the vast
majority of consumers use the Play Store
in addition it's not illegal to have a
monopoly like you can't be penalized
just for building a good product and
being successful however a monopoly
becomes illegal when you explo the
market either through price
discrimination exclusive dealings or
tying contracts now epic games has also
been fighting a similar battle with the
Apple App Store but it mostly lost that
case and that ruling was recently held
up after they appealed I didn't hear no
Bell but yesterday epic games won a
unanimous decision where the jury said
that Google engages in anti-competitive
Behavior Google will appeal but why did
Apple win and Google lose well that's
where things get interesting Apple has
an entirely closed off system a Walled
Garden where iOS is not open source and
they don't allow alternative app stores
for or iOS devices you can think of
Apple phones and the App Store as all
part of the same product and developers
have nowhere else to go everybody has to
think different in the exact same way
now that feels more unfair compared to
Google's ecosystem where the operating
system is open source there are multiple
app stores out there and Google even has
an alternative inapp purchases program
although it's currently just a pilot
program now in Apple's case developers
have nowhere to go but in Google's case
they need to convince developers that
the Google Play Store is their best
option one thing we learned about in the
case is Project hug give me a hug no way
come here I'm not coming over there
let's go forget it a project where
Google offered game developers tens of
millions of dollars and even offered
epic games $147 million to launch
fortnite on Google Play the thing is
though these payments didn't block a
developer from launching on another
platform as long as they launched on
Google Play the same day so it doesn't
really look like they're trying to block
other app stores except there's also
these internal documents like this one
where a Play Store executive brags about
how they got Riot games creator of
League of Legends to stop development on
its own app store game developers are
absolute cash cows for the App Stores
and the company bragged internally about
how it's one of the most profitable
businesses in the world but these cash
cows can't be milked if they take their
games to their own platforms as a
small-time developer it's important to
understand that the top 1% gets treated
differently companies like Spotify can
bypass App Store fees and Netflix was
offered a 10% cut in addition Google had
agreements with Chinese oems to give
manufacturers a cut of Play Store fees
to prevent them from pre-installing
other app stores and for all these
reasons the jury decided that Google did
a big no no I guess the lesson to be
learned here is that if you want to
dominate Tech build a fully closed off
system like apple and don't try to build
an open system like Google where you
need secret deals to dominate it now the
next step is for epic and Google to get
back together in January to remedy the
lawsuit epic doesn't want money though
it wants fundamental changes to the way
the app stores work which is likely good
news for all the mobile developers out
there but this is all one guy's fault
Tim Sweeney at one point Google even
considered taking a large stake in epic
games but then decided against it once
they found out that Tim Sweeney was the
controlling shareholder because he's a
bit of an outlier gigachad as far as
Tech millionaires go and the fact that
he had the balls to go up against big
Tech and actually won ironically
embodies this quote from Steve Jobs the
ones who are crazy enough to think they
can change the world are the ones who do
this has been the code report thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one